day one when I went blind it was all I
thought about it was 100% of my life by
the time I arrived at the South Pole the
blankness was about 1 percent of my life
the rest of it was filled a 99% was
filled with other interesting things I'm
following the same approach to my
paralysis
to rebuild my identity I really had to
get back in a boat I got more and more
interested in endurance sports and I
started to do long-distance races in the
Gobi Desert we did six marathons in a
week in the Gobi Desert in northwest
China then we went to do a marathon at
the North Pole and eventually ten years
after I lost my sight I did a 40
three-day expedition race to the to the
South Pole I had my accident when I was
34 I fell from a window onto the
concrete below and I fractured my skull
bleeds on my brain massive internal
injuries and ultimately I couldn't feel
her move everything from my stomach down
so I spent the following 18 months in
hospital my new south pole my new
adventure is to try and explore the
possibility of walking again
some people find their wheelchair a huge
liberator and have no interest in doing
the exploring the possibilities of
recovery I find sitting in the chair
being very inactive being pushed really
I'm physically very inactive so when I
get up into the into the exo it starts
to stretch our legs my tendons my toes
stop curling over my hips loose night
the spasms I get my legs disappear I
feel better just by standing
it just seems to loosen every part of my
body and it just feels right this feels
right to be up okay GUP
mmm
I'm not taking any weight and of the
device so I'm the device is sort of
standing itself and if I wasn't enough
it could stand up on its own all right
group that was a big one it's taken me a
long time to to work out what paralysis
means for me for me and people like me
there is no cure for spinal cord injury
so I'm sitting somewhere in between
reality and fantasy right now and the
wheelchair and no cure is the reality no
and the fantasy is that there may be a
cure one day and we may be able to walk
so I'm operating somewhere in between
those two places
you